a disaster like this we never had in
life before and there's only one chance
we need we need a change and a change
mean that we have to vote Prince Ali
after all this what happened in the last
10 20 years and now what we hear again
you cannot just say yeah but I'm clean I
had nothing to do with it it said this
has been going on for a long time and
bladders been there for a long time so
it's quite hard to believe I suppose
that he didn't have some suspicion of
something that was going on if you'll
give away the TV rights for one one
dollar do it to an li you know in
exchange of votes then maybe it's not
corruption but it's serious
mismanagement for all the innuendo and
the and the labeling that sir Blatter
where's there has never been any hard
evidence put forward that said bladder
is corrupt or that he ever took bribes
what happened is that a lot of other
people did that during his governance
and that's where he's he's been labeled
with me stuff now for just about the
rest of his life if it is true what I
read in the newspapers that 10 million
dollars has been remitted from the FIFA
to an American account don't tell me
that the executive president of FIFA
doesn't know about it this all happened
on his watch and you've got to ask the
question you know when these things
happen on somebody's watch is it right
to keep that person in charge